I thought would start off with the
experience that was and I had last
Tuesday we went down to the Center for
Constitutional Rights and they were
giving a seminar for various donors and
Geeta along with her presentation talked
about the fact that we have to now
recognize that what we thought was a
temporary condition has become permanent
and that she meant not only the fact
that Guantanamo he's opening but all of
the legislation that has were passed the
anti Muslim terrorism that is a
permanent part of our world now and I
was wondering if you could comment on is
that too bleak a way of looking at the
world or do you think that's what the
reality of how reality really is I said
I think one has to look on look at
history over a longer span I think there
are probably from the late 19th century
there have been particular tensions in
fact ironically by the middle of the
19th century the use of torture have
been abolished in Western countries
previously it had been permitted to be
applied a judicial device legally
permissible to obtain the truth circled
and that have been discontinued but by
the end of the 19th century there was a
growth of state agencies espionage
police military intelligence that came
into being as as arms of the state that
claimed that they should not be bound by
the restrictions of customary
legislation
and there was simultaneously a
long-running legal concept for many
centuries of what you could call the
exceptional crime and to my mind the
history of the 20th century and the
history of their first ten years of this
century is a constant tension among
states many states of those principles
that that there are there are offenses
or crimes that should never be committed
the use of torture extrajudicial killing
destruction of human rights these are
impermissible and states know it but
intention with that is the concept that
there are some emergencies and there are
some arms of the state who are justified
in destroying those rights and so I
think one has to look at the march of
history to see how those tensions play
out and I don't think one can just say
in the last 10 years something new has
happened I don't agree with that I think
if you look over a longer span if you
look post-world war two at the
international resolutions that we should
never do this again that states should
police each other and all of the heroic
international treaties to ensure that we
should never do it UN Declaration of
Human Rights European Convention on
Human Rights if you consider those and
then you consider that within a handful
of years the French were torturing
Algerians in fact jean-paul Sartre said
how can it be that when the
screams from the torture chambers of the
Gestapo have barely subsided that we the
French are doing this to others horrific
Lee and we the British were doing this
to the Mau Mau in the 1950s and so you
know we we do well to revisit and
sharpen our knowledge of of history to
understand that there is never a pure
victory over abuse of Human Rights there
never is it's never static there was
there's always the the ability to resort
for claimed reasons of pragmatism to the
forbidden and that's what we in Britain
have done and that's what America's are
done during the last ten years but we
did it before and we did it ourselves in
Britain throughout the conflict in
Northern Ireland shamefully and it's
what we did that fuelled the fires of
that conflict where estate perpetrates
injustice and where the state gives no
remedy against that perpetration then
that fuels reaction and violent reaction
as a listen to the two sets of
conditions going on one of the
circumstances of the claiming of special
circumstances and the other or the
agency certain agencies consider but we
seem to be living at a time when people
are proclaiming that the circumstances
not temporary permanent that we live in
a permanent condition of warfare on
terror the whole idea of the war on
terror
so open-ended is so permanent and we
live in at least in the States I feel
this all the time we live in a situation
in which the replication of agencies of
the state you know with the passage of
the homeland defense after the creation
of new agencies and new powers for new
agencies it's kind of like it's its
ceaseless is or is that just to depress
know of course that there's an an
endless appetite for expansion of state
powers and that is nothing new if you if
you revisit the correspondence between
madison and jefferson when the tyrant
had been overthrown their whole
discussion of what was needed whether it
was needed to have a bill of rights the
whole discussion was considering how to
legislate against themselves for the
future because there will always be a
temptation to do that and in fact what
we have now is the paradox in many ways
we have certainly our country and
America I have situations of enormous
state power and strength and stability
and resources to coerce or suppress or
our respective states are internally and
externally strong and yet at the same
time you have an extraordinary developed
neurosis to suggest that the state is
somehow suddenly acutely vulnerable and
it's to my mind a misconception
perhaps we have some ability to to see
it in more than one way because we have
been through 25 years of armed conflict
in relation to the affairs of the north
of Ireland and so we have had that
experience of bombs going off in London
frequently massive attacks upon the
cities in which we live in England and
our neighbors in the north of Ireland
have lived through a war a war that
lived in a war zone and yet here we are
and if one has had the chance of looking
at the narrative of how we came out of
that period of intense conflict one can
see the history of state action and
reaction the IRA could not recruit until
Bloody Sunday after the British Army had
shot dead 13 innocent civilians
protesting peacefully for their rights
civil rights there was no shortage of
volunteers for the IRA and every state
injustice brought about a reaction and
at the end the IRA had to be talked to
they had to be and one of the
recurrent daily observations we have of
the claimed never-ending war on terror
is the utter failure to learn from
history and to have some kind of Saint
analysis of whether perceived enemies
our enemies and we we see not Egypt or
we supported Mubarak and his torturing
regime for 20-30 years Tunisia Syria all
of these in the past months two months
we have come to see those we call
terrorists were dissenters in England we
had many Libyan dissidents whose focus
of political activity until they fled
and gained refugia focus of activity was
simply removing Gaddafi but we called
them terrorists here we subjected them
to internment without trial attempts to
deport them to a country where we knew
they would be tortured we arrived at
diplomatic accommodations with Gaddafi
and we said we claimed that they will be
safe if they were deported there because
there was a Gaddafi foundation headed by
south Gaddafi his son it's laughable
it's insane but we pursue our perceived
economic strategic objectives to the
exclusion of a same approach to justice
we simply do and we don't learn from our
history very recently in the High Court
in London
there were a number of elderly men and
women who had been members of the Mau
Mau in Kenya 50 years ago and they were
bringing an action against the British
government for the men had been
castrated the women had been raped there
have been unspeakable tortures committed
by the British Army and Foreign Office
documents at surfaced at the time they
brought their action which demonstrated
it wasn't rogue soldiers it was systemic
it was ordered from the top and so with
the very shallow labeling and the shower
shallow use of concept of who is the
enemy who is not the enemy has to be
revisited it is not well it is possible
sadly to continue all forever but it
isn't sane and in the process we destroy
the very few things that we say we hold
sacred those difficult rights of due
process procedural rights and difficult
to fight for if they apply to the
outlaws or outcasts of society nobody
considers they deserve them but we
we need to bring ourselves up short we
have we have had the opportunity in this
country we have a new government to a
year ago coalition government and
because so many truly terrible things
happened under the Labour government in
which there was a conscious destruction
again from the top just like bonamo
complicity in torture complicity in
rendition the new the new government
announced that it wanted to draw a line
under the past and it ordered a public
inquiry into our complicity in torture
and the men who had come back from
Guantanamo the British citizens and
British residents 15 of them had been
for two years suing the government for
conspiracy to torture and kidnap and the
new coalition government said that it
wished to negotiate and settle those
claims but in the course of the civil
litigation you get disclosure grudge
grudging disclosure we sued mi5 mi6
Foreign Office Home Office the Attorney
General and before the final negotiation
we had begun to get disclosure of some
of the internal documents and they were
profoundly disturbing the
the government had said publicly we're
doing everything we can to get these men
back from Guantanamo we deplore
Guantanamo but if you look at the early
email into departmental traffic as the
Home Secretary the Foreign Secretary the
Prime Minister saying explicitly send
them to Guantanamo send them there we
don't want them back in England this is
British citizens knowing it was from one
unlawful black hole in background to
another in Guantanamo saying the longer
they stay there the better saying this
one in Zambia could be saved if we have
consular access an email back saying
this is from number 10 do not give him
consular access so it's a shameful it's
a shameful story I've read a couple of
articles where we make that connection
between the the campaign ad the
terrorism against the IRA and the rocker
Guantanamo island with Muslims do today
and I was trying to think of as there's
a kind of segue from one to the other in
the writing in England I was trying to
think of what is comparable in the
United States you know this does not
come just with Guantanamo but there has
to be a history after nine eleven they
were so prepared instantly to enact the
legislation they had it prepared just
kind of a similar situation sense of
this feeling that the state apparatus
must engage in Terry in order
sir survive you compare the English in
the Americas situations at all I think
Americans were more overt about what
they did Bush Cheney Rumsfeld they said
what they were doing torture is
internationally prohibited there is no
defense if you are involved in torture
has no defense of superior orders or
necessity and so what the Americans did
was redefine some of the mechanics of
torture in order to give immunity to
those who who were carrying it out so
waterboarding was read was defined as
not torture but um a British were
complicit but not overt in what they did
but yet they knew and they should have
known they should have recognized
prohibited techniques if if you if you
talk to men who were in held in Bagram
in January 2002 they were in a in a vast
disused air hangar in a freezing cold of
an Afghan winter and they were in thin
clothes sitting on concrete floors in
stress positions made to sit in a static
position hour after hour with just
reservoir round them not allowed to talk
at all to each other and the
interrogation rooms were overlooking
these cages of reservoir and you could
hear everyone could hear the screams and
the noise from there and there were
rooms on the ground floor where if the
door opened you could see men hanging by
their wrists and if you talk to those
British citizens or British residents
who were held at that time there do you
ask them
were there British agents there and they
say you could see them walking two by
two along the reservoir and they could
see everything they could hear
everything so we know that a message
came back to their superiors saying we
are seeing things is this permissible
and the advice the legal advice came
back provided you are not the ones doing
it literally physically doing it it's
fine carry on so here's the information
to give to the interrogators let us have
the product back and that's complicity
in torture that's just as prohibited as
being the ones who do the physical
damage and that's what we've done and
that's what we're still doing we have
close relationships with countries that
torture we send them information we get
information back for what it's worth
from the dr. chambers and there's been a
pitched battle in this country over many
years to expose that and prevent prevent
the use of it there's been a pitched
battle going on and yet we should know
since Alan took the United Kingdom to
the european court of human rights in
the 70s for using precisely those
techniques stress positions hooding use
of extreme cold use of extreme noise
that's what we did and is prohibited and
we know it
but we the methodology for eradicated
torture that the accepted methodology is
to stranded one is to get the data you
have to know exactly who did what to
whom and when you need clear a
verifiable detail you need doctors to
check to prove you need corroborating
evidence you need to know and the second
strand is to ensure that those on whose
watch it happened to brought to book and
we have we have a problem in Britain in
particular because although we say we've
forsworn a number of things we haven't
full sworn secrecy and that's our one of
our particular national vices that if
the state claims that it's in the
interests of national security not to
reveal something that trumps everything
here and so although the government has
ordered an inquiry into our complicity
in torture particularly in relation to
the Guantanamo former detainees it's
going to be in secret and those who were
involved or responsible will give their
evidence and secret and so it's it's a
fallacy that that is capable of
acting as a corrective it's a total
fallacy we have the same problem not
quite the same I think I think America
has has a greater degree considerably
greater degree of openness Ivan did
whistleblowers are protected species in
the United States they're certainly not
here and unsanitary congressional
hearings have a much greater practical
experience of pressing for detail in a
public forum it's possible but the will
doesn't seem to be there okay Congress
so that would be the difference yes the
Congress seems to be willing just go
along with the President on ours I think
there are particular moments when there
is a crisis of embarrassment or exposure
and it's those moments which taken up
the flood and certainly our grave was
one there were pictures and that made an
enormous difference and quite similar
circumstances here and some of the
British forces in Iraq have been
responsible for brutal killings and the
use of torture and ironically because
they've been court-martials or inquests
ironically then the military have been
exposed to a far greater degree in terms
of investigation findings
recommendations prosecution's far
greater degree than the intelligence
services all the relevant ministries but
i think i think the lesson we learn is
that if you look at the Mau Mau and you
realize that it was all there that it
was from the top it was systemic it
involved those on the ground who carried
out unspeakable acts had any of those
had it been in the public domain and had
everyone concerned been prosecuted
sentence maybe to life including
ministers who authorized it senior
military officer civil servants if that
had happened he would I think never have
had the same happening again in the
north of Ireland who would never have
had complicity in Guantanamo complicity
in parkland you would never have it
because they would know the consequences
one of the reasons we're of grandeur
taking this project is to document the
full range of the history of Guantanamo
and part of those documentation of the
torture of the detainees yes which is
difficult to do in an American situation
because none of the detainees will ever
be allowed into the United States so
here I was wondering if you could tell
when we were talking off tape about when
when the tipton Jepsen Tipton came home
I was wondering if you tell that that
story for us is a way of further
documenting that um Shafiq Rasul was the
older one of the three and then two
young ones at rural armored and asif
iqbal there oh very young and when they
came back they were arrested and
detained as shear tokenism to show that
there was some kind of investigation
going on into their supposed involvement
in terrorism everybody knew that was
nonsense but so for one night they were
in Paddington Green police station and
it was dangerous for them to go back to
the west midlands were they lived walls
they have been in Guantanamo there have
been very active racist interest in
where they lived to have been effigies
hung on lampposts outside their houses
and the police in fact suggested they
should not go home or not for a while
and and they stayed for a while in the
house I live in and so in the most
fortunate circumstance in order just to
be able to talk to two survivors from
the most terrible ordeal they have come
back from hell and there were three very
young men sitting around the kitchen
table and simultaneously talking about
some of the horrors and there were too
many to tell and looking at their new
mobile telephones and flicking them on
and off but without proper knowledge and
in hindsight with regret without
comprehending how difficult it was for
the victim of trauma to revisit that
drama and we we made them sit down on
and off for about a month and tell
because they were the first to come out
the only ones who knew only ones who had
any idea of explaining what had happened
which which was extraordinary
extraordinary to hear that this have
been done by human beings to other human
beings and by Americans
they it was the time of Abu Ghraib in
fact it was exactly that time and there
were those photographs which were too
shocking to ignore but there were no
photographs of Guantanamo and then never
have been and there probably never will
be of the torture okay no pictures of
Nan in orange suits in humiliating
positions when they get off the plane
when I first taken now that's the
triumphalist picture of their captor but
there was nothing to show what had been
done to them and so they they showed um
someone who just spent time looking at
the different horrible positions they
contorted themselves into someone spent
time sketching those and that was the
next best thing to photographs with
their account but they had been in
Guantanamo for nearly three years and
they were very young two of them have
been teenagers and they came out with
that strength and resilience of youth
and they had each other and that was
important but in the years since I think
in our profound ignorance we've come to
understand much more of the kind of
irreparable damage the use of torture
inflicts upon a human being they're all
the roughly young men and and they're
very good they've all found employment
they've trained in a skill they're all
married they have children they're
living good lives as are all of the men
who've come back from Guantanamo all of
them but if you talk just a little bit
and they're willing to tell you they're
all haunted they wake up in the night
they can't live comfortably with their
families in contained premises they need
space and isolation they have flashbacks
all the time of the torture and that
can't be removed that's there and
physically you know they have terrible
pain their backs have gone it's quite
extraordinary or what man does to man
and they knew from the beginning that
these three young men were nothing they
knew that but yet they chained them held
them hour after hour after hour in
freezing cold in Guantanamo until they
all confessed that yes it was them in a
video with a summer bin Laden they
confessed to it but it turned out
because there was a date on the video as
possible to establish they'd all been
working in an electronic shop in Tipton
at that very time so the concept that
torture produces the truth is insanity
it's complete insanity and that you know
sanity sanity was arrived at by the mid
19th century on that issue that torture
didn't produce truth and that its use
degraded a society
and yet here we are again with this
deranged concept that that the end
justifies the means and the means are
useful let alone okay this one British
resident left Shaka owner why is he
still there when all the others appear
we don't we don't completely know he's
never been charged with something the
Americans have never framed a charge on
any evidence but yet it appears that
they have in their minds that he is
somehow dangerous because it seems
simply because he has an extremely
charismatic presence a powerful
personality which in Guantanamo has had
effect on other prisoners
in terms of discussion of complaining
resisting but that appears to be it but
at the same time the British have been
appalling Lee week or worse and was
Shaka several years ago the time Binyam
Mohammed came back the Foreign Office
wrote to shakas wife and said we're
closing the file we're not going to do
any more for him he has a British wife
British children here and it was only at
the time of the negotiation of the legal
action of the other Guantanamo men
you've been returned that
the government he woke up to what was a
catastrophe because as they sat down to
negotiate every man said I don't want
money I want Chaka back all of them they
had a private meeting with a very senior
minister and what one could see was that
the minister must have asked a senior
civil servants and said well why isn't
about what's going on and they had to
confess that actually they've done
nothing to get him back so now there's a
supposed energized attempt and recently
two days ago few days ago President
Obama was here in Hillary Clinton and
jacket armor was the subject of meetings
but we have had such deceit over so many
years we we really believe very little
we were told for so many years we've
trying to get them back we're trying to
persuade the Americans and then years
later we see these emails saying the
longer they stay there the better it
leads it's to a very bleak cynicism you
mentioned the earth European Court you
know I have been interviewing some
gloves today appealed they're frustrated
because the American Supreme Court has
in effectively closed down with the
weaker case of close down the DC
district course is closed down it is the
European Court a record of resort for
you here there are some cases before the
European caught at the moment that have
a resonance and those are a number of
men in different cases where America is
seeking their extradition their British
and America has extended its
jurisdictional appetite to say that
they've committed offences travel in
America and there are two issues in
which the court has asked for more
evidence most missions more questions
one is the imposition of life without
parole and the other is use of extreme
solitary confinement in supermax prisons
and it's accepted that each of these men
might face both both of those prospects
and so the European Court has asked the
question does the Eighth Amendment of
the US Constitution provide equivalent
protection to article 3 of the European
Convention which prohibits torture and
cruel and inhuman and degrading
treatment and the answer is curiously we
say no because we have a love and
respect for the American Constitution
and it has been surprising and shocking
to us that case law on the Eighth
Amendment in terms of it
ocular solitary confinement case law in
America says the Eighth Amendment
entitles the prisoner to shelter and
warmth and food but human association is
not a human right where are the all of
the expert evidence and research shows
overwhelmingly that to confine someone
before a extended period of time or even
not an extent period of time can produce
madness can produce psychosis at the
very minimum produces acute
psychological and psychiatric effects
but America makes use of extreme
isolation for tens of thousands of
prisoners tens of thousands of prisoners
of which was the Pelican Bay are just
incredibly we we we have been shocked to
appreciate as a result of litigating
these cases the extent to which prisons
have been purpose built designed by
architects to centrally deprive human
beings and men confined in a tiny steel
cell not just for a week or a month year
after year after year and potentially
for life no human no human mind could
survive that if the European Court finds
and it hasn't yet arrived at a decision
if it finds that
such conditions including life without
any hope of parole would violate article
3 it will refuse the UK permission to
extradite to America and I don't know if
that would have any impact at all but a
previous case the case of suring was a
man extradited to be extradited from
here to the US who faced the death
penalty and the European Court
prohibited extradition to
a form of imprisonment which would
involve what's described as the death
row syndrome and so no European country
now no country is allowed to extradite
to another country anywhere in the world
if there is the potential of the death
penalty and so what America has done
since case of suring has given
assurances written government assurances
to say that death penalty would not wish
be sought so there is that limited
indirect and potential of effecting in a
minor way how American might look at
what it does even states there was a
moment of euphoria or a moment of
optimism when Obama was elected with
that replicated here at all oh yes
absolutely one of the most extraordinary
not just images but experiences was to
see the president obama inaugurated was
it was a resolution it seemed of the
terrible terrible history of slavery and
the experiences of those who fought for
civil rights the voter registration
movement that day when Obama was
inaugurated was the most extraordinary
day and we felt it here and there is no
taking away from that it was and it
remains something utterly magnificent in
our history what is happening now is
progression any politician coming to
power finds his or her way in governing
and that is difficult but the
expectations that were placed upon Obama
and the gulf between those and the
delivery has been substantial and he is
he's a consensus politician and he's up
against a considerable movement within
the Republican Party to row back on
issues like trial by military commission
in fact I think two days ago Congress
passed legislation saying that no
foreign terrorists could be prosecuted
before a jury
which makes us wonder about these
extradition cases and because some years
ago America had to give a diplomatic
assurance in these cases that they would
not be made enemy combatants that they
would stand trial before a jury but now
Congress has brought this in so no the
the ability to maintain good intentions
is supremely difficult and Obama's a law
professor then you know he should know
better than than some of some of the
decisions he's he's made in looking at
the history of this kind of impressed
with the fact that in the UK you've been
able to mount a public campaign yeah
further before the release
parliamentarians political people who
are actively in the political world
where that seems to be impossible in the
United States a campaign um on water
pressure to pressure the government in
order to pressure the United States
release the prisoners from going there
were leaked his briefs with parma
charians don't be don't be deceived
don't be deceived that was not
necessarily it was a good press a
clear-cut course I promise you it wasn't
but there were there were certain key
triggers that took brought things much
more to a head and one was in 2003 there
was an announcement by the Americans
that they were building a death chamber
in Guantanamo and that
to think it was four or six the first
men to be placed before a military
commission on trial would include two
British men firoza basia moisan Beck and
that just hit in particular the Daily
Mail as a conservative patriotic
newspaper the thought that British men
were going to be executed by the
Americans was a step too far and across
the board there was a reaction and it
had multiple ingredients multiple
ingredients of campaigners and no legal
initiatives were tried one way and
another including Shafiq Rasul from
Tipton by an accident of fate his
brother had asked for legal
representation here thing is there
anything you could do at the same time
that lawyers in america were looking for
an identified individual in Guantanamo
because identities were not known and as
I remember there have been a class
action initiated in California almost
immediately by the ACLU I think which
didn't get off the ground because they
didn't have a name but he was shafiq
Russell and so there were lawyers
they're looking and here's mr. Asselin
hero faxes affidavits boom among get the
Habeas we're involved in getting that
name to the chief ER oh absolutely yes
it was a very happy encounter indeed yes
and so you know there have been
different ways in
issues have been had been progressed one
significant player in the campaigning
was a moistened eggs father who had been
a banker and he was a very composed very
dignified quite traditional person and
he spoke here there everywhere and he
was impressive to people he carried with
him an authentic credibility and so it
came about and through a range of
pressures that it became profoundly
uncomfortable for the then government to
continue to do nothing and so suddenly
you had the Attorney General little
Goldsmith tearing back and forth across
the Atlantic and when you come later on
to see some of the email traffic you see
the hypocrisy same tunnel telex is going
saying we're okay but with military
commissions from this end the same time
trumpeting we're doing everything we can
to get Moyes and back back that they had
to start doing something as more
embarrassing not to do something than to
do something that's the point you've got
to get to that's the point when you were
talking about when we're talking about
Obama and combination of the civil
rights movement it is my mind that you
had been in the united states with
martin luther king at a point in time so
there has a certain poignancy for you
and
for the 10 years between 1960 and 1970
like the whole of the rest of the world
one watched with or that the courage of
of those in the civil rights movement
who who risked all learn to achieve what
they achieved and that's that's the
reason isn't it why when Obama was
inaugurated that enveloped all of that
history in just one what did you said
you were you were in the States
this is personal okay with a buddy
you've been twice at least I know
another words testimony for the LAN
Tuscany committee and I Ireland okay you
do you did you testify before the
congressional committee congressman
Atlanta's I i I've certainly testified I
think for two congressional committees
one in one on the Birmingham six who
were only convicted and maybe I haven't
maybe I haven't I'm not sure I certainly
went to Washington in relation to number
of cases of wrongly convicted men here
and got sympathy encouragement when you
talk about litter getting the facts the
variable verifiable yes how are we to do
that huh
it's very it's very easy if there's a
will for instance in Greece after the
fall of the military junta the the new
Greek and government ordered an
exhaustive inquiry into those who have
been the victims of torture by the junta
and the report the findings that they
made were extraordinarily detailed and
important that an object lesson in how
to do it as long as those people all
those interests remain in power that
have had a hand in and hand in it it is
deliberately made almost impossible or
very different difficult but if you take
the models of post-revolutionary society
or in a dramatic deliberate change in
society then of course there's the
potential and post apartheid South
Africa set up the model of truth the
truth commissions and and so the concept
of Truth and Reconciliation comes with
the message you can't have
reconciliation without knowing the truth
and there is a constant theme in the
north of Ireland to get to grips with
the secrets of the past and a Savile
inquiry
took an enormous amount of time to
investigate bloody sunday i think at the
end ironically they didn't they
chickened out of showing that it did
indeed go to the top but it was
important of huge importance to the
farmers to have the innocence of their
their family members who've been
murdered recognized and to have it
acknowledged that it was murdered by the
state that was important it would be
kind of easy to see Guantanamo as an
American problem how do you see it as a
British problem or international problem
I think it's the most avert example of
something that goes on in a covert way
all the time there's country after
country after country that detains
people unlawfully without due process
and with the complicity of other
countries and this is just on a very big
scale and too big to be a kept secret
but almost every country visited
Guantanamo for its own purposes if it
had a national there or someone in whom
was interested almost every country went
there fed in information derived what it
could out of Guantanamo so it was a
joint venture to be honest
what we were talking you there there are
two aspects to working out of Kent
problematic my words prob night one was
gaining verifiable information the other
was a sense of justice what would
justice look like for the perpetrators
of Guantanamo and those who allowed in
current you mean can anyone be booked
just yes value today personal justice
would it be is some institutional just
what would justice well at the moment
there is a police investigation
continuing into the potential complicity
of particular and my five mi six
officers in relation to us detentions of
individuals at those early stages in
2002 and in a way whether or not those
individuals were prosecuted is not what
interests most people particularly those
most affected the victims if there is
evidence of a much bigger picture then
it's that bigger picture that needs to
be seen I'd I do believe that I mean for
instance there is the war crimes
tribunal which has from time to time
prosecutions of
individuals who have had senior roles in
particular sustained atrocities there
are there are many senior people
politicians or civil servants who could
on the basis of the law and facts that
we are aware of all ready and be
prosecuted and my view is although I
have no particular interest in one
individual or another being in the dock
it's not a personal or vindictive
approach my view is that unless you do
prosecute these practices will simply go
on and on and on and on and so in
another 10 years another 20 years it
will go on again and and the only way to
bring a halt to it is to expose what's
being done and to bring those two book
who did it it's similar to the earlier
discussion of the failure to do
something like that with no environment
of the IRA the failure to prosecute
perpetrators
your earlier if we had yes yes and
instead for instance with Bloody Sunday
instead of court-martialing soldiers who
had shot unarmed civilians we not only
condoned it but the Lord Chief Justice
whittier was brought in to conduct a
review and he produced an utterly
mendacious whitewash and and that was
causative of reaction of the most
profound kind and so it's the the
distorting the distorting of processes
and the distorting and contamination of
the law to twist it around and use it in
an abusive way that is profoundly
corrosive of society and so that that
imperative to have honesty and as a
result of honesty consequences
appropriate consequences it remains
critically important but in Britain will
we ever achieve it not as long as we are
so devoted to the concept of secrecy the
last question is were where do you think
we're going to go would you what just
tomorrow hold
think the lesson the lesson to learn is
that there is no pinnacle of enlightened
achievement that simply sustains itself
there isn't a sunny plateau that you
remain on that the tensions we've
discussed that lead states constantly to
look for or to adopt procedures outside
of legal convention and the recognition
that NASA the less there are legal
conventions they have to be adhere to
that constant battle I think is there
forever and therefore will has to be
alert and on the watch and keeping God
and fighting for it and that means the
whole of society and that's difficult it
isn't what interests most people it
isn't what affects most people's lives
and that nevertheless it's poisonous
when it when it infects and ultimately
it doesn't do any good it doesn't make
society safe it makes it less safe and
it reproduces itself and open-ended ly
learning history being aware of our
history all of us and doesn't hurt thank
you very much
you